wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute wo wir morgen sind
wieder alles neu begeht
also liebe leute schön dass wieder dabei
seid was wir nicht heute auf einem
münchner flohmarkt wir sind dabei etwas
zu suchen und hoffentlich so finden für
unser musikvideo ein paar schöne
requisiten
hast du überhaupt arbeiten ich geld habe
ich nicht genug dabei aber wir sind auch
auf einem flohmarkt auf einem flohmarkt
mit gewöhnlich gehandelt und gefeilscht
es zurück
im land des versoffenen selber für das
musikvideo
ich geb dir 5766 15 44 euro
gerne greifen zu müssen
übrigen zu kommen
wenn sie sagen sie sind ein richtiger
sammler ich sammle alles was schönes
wohnen wo ich was lernen aus alte schöne
dinge die ich retten verhalten
reparieren und bewahren
und hier habe ich abgestaubt
schellackplatten keller meine
grammophone
ist eine welt im kleinen erde immer
wieder findet eine vergangene welt aber
vielleicht auch da sollte man genau
darüber nachdenken die welt der zukunft
in die welt der zukunft ist eine die
sich rückbesinnen muss auf das was gutes
gab und was es erhaltenswertes gab sich
mit nachhaltigkeit ressourcen
all diese dinge aber hier das doch bei
dir auch schon staubfänger oder
also mit 60 gb an 55555 kann er dennoch
nehmen
bei 60
richtig gute schnäppchen gemacht hatte
etwas essen